now A desperate situation is unfolding
on Chad's the eastern border with Sudan
thousands of people are fleeing violence
in the westar4 region and seeking
shelter wherever they can find it Aid
agencies say medical facilities in the
Border Town of Adria overwhelmed by
hundreds of injured civilians many
children who've been left without their
parents are starving to death
Ravi has more from the Chad Sudan border
at an old school outside Audrey the
chadian government is housing thousands
of refugees who cross from Sudan in just
the last few days
no matter where you go the sound of
children crying follows
[Music]
it is crowded there is no hygiene people
are desperate squabbling for food water
even the smallest patch of shade
my son was shot and we left him behind
three of my children came the others
didn't make it
we left Janina without sheets shoes or
clothes without food we haven't eaten
anything my father was killed they
chased us and beat us the children we
left Behind still haven't arrived we
couldn't bury the dead we just had to
leave them behind
forced from their homes walking for days
robbed of possessions and beaten some
began cooking leaves to survive
they say they need help now every other
person you speak to seems to be a
witness to a murder they've seen
Terrible Things experienced unimaginable
hardships to come this far and now the
question is how to get them help where
do they go next what happens now
a visit by chadian President Muhammad
Idris Debbie itna brings with it a
bounty of at least one meal a day
for most here it is their first in days
we asked an army officer if it would
continue after the president left his
answer you tell me
there are no long-term Solutions right
now only temporary remedies
eight organizations admit they are
underfunded and playing catch-up because
International donors are ignoring the
crisis as the number of refugees
continues to grow
during a meeting with Aid groups the
president warned the war next door will
not be over anytime soon
the number of refugees he said could hit
one million
Zain basaravi Al Jazeera Audrey Eastern
Chad
a new three-day ceasefire in Sudan which
started early on Sunday appears to be
holding Aid agencies are hoping the
pause in fighting will allow them to
safely deliver much needed humanitarian
Aid Heber Morgan reports from the city
of onderman near the capital of Khartoum
people here in the capital hartum are
divided about the latest ceasefire most
are happy about the respite and fighting
giving them the chance to stock up on
basic necessities such as food and water
especially in residential neighborhoods
which have been cut off from running
water since the start of the fighting
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army in mid-april others are
taking the opportunity to leave the
capital saying that they're worried once
the 72 hours ceasefire expires there
will be more intense fighting between
the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army but some residents
especially in the Northern parts of the
capital Khartoum who we spoke to say
that they're concerned about an uptick
of robberies and home occupations by the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
that's because during the last ceasefire
which lasted for 24 hours there was a
noticeable increase in the number of
home invasions and occupation by the
paramilitary rapid support forces as
reported by residents some of those who
we spoke to say that this ceasefire is
between rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army and that it involves only
military movements but when it comes to
the issues of Home occupation allowing
civilians to access what they need or
leave their homes or stay in their homes
then they have not been taken into
account there's been no fighting
reported on Sunday the first day of the
72-hour ceasefire but people say that
they are worried that because of the
duration because it's for 72 hours then
the two sides may not refrain from any
military movement the mediators Saudi
Arabia and the United States made it
very clear that there should be no use
of heavy artillery between the rsf and
the Sudanese Army no use of surveillance
drones and no use of fighter jets so
fighting from any side is not allowed
under this new ceasefire and should the
ceasefire be violated then talks in the
Saudi city of Jeddah which is hoped to
lead to a permanent ceasefire between
the two sides to end the fighting here
in the capital hartum and around the
country will be adjourned